[Music]
so you're probably thinking right now
what have I got myself into when I was
your age I was getting in trouble so I
getting arrested I know what it's like
his charges are very serious he's facing
up to life in prison
you've been running in and out of jail
happy your life where you're charged
aside you're warned the boot camp
program is an alternative to 20 years in
prison
don't squander this opportunity you'll
feel right now but you're lucky you're
lucky because you got another shot don't
[ __ ] this thing up I mean that well you
get the boot camp want me to stop your
life oh you do you're gonna beat that
demon out of you
you want to treat some in chronic we
have one mission one missing only that's
a thank you from quite some this.top
this.right Yahweh got you oh but now
things are gonna change because you have
everything to lose
this is a form of rehabilitation
I know this we can't program I believe
in it I want the world to see the
importance of this program are you ready
go minimize book available for the
program you will be sentenced to seven
years in the state prison you don't
started out of criminals but boot camp
gave us a second chance
you will gave us a second chance
may not be able to see it right now but
that's your new life
you